a quanti di voi si è già impallato il
computer
almeno una volta nella vita
quindi se vi è già successo sapete che
di solito capita perché abbiamo troppi
programmi aperti
forse troppo finestre aperte stiamo
facendo il cosiddetto multi tasking si è
già successo sapete che a volte il modo
migliore per farlo rifunzionare e
schiacciare il tasto reset oppure
staccare la spina e questo è quello che
succede con il cervello elettronico ma
non è molto diverso da quello che
succede con il cervello umano
provate a pensare a quanti minuti
quante ore della nostra giornata
passiamo sempre connessi il cellulare
ormai il primo oggetto che prendiamo in
mano la mattina e l'ultimo che
abbandoniamo la sera ormai è diventato
normale camminare con il cellulare in
mano
quello di cui forse non siamo
consapevoli è quante notizie
quante informazioni quante fonti di
stress
quante emozioni proviamo durante la
giornata questo senza prenderci un
attimo per staccare la spina e allora
può capitare che anche noi andiamo in
tilt in realtà è così semplice prendersi
un attimo per respirare o no se andiamo
in tilt cosa che probabilmente c'è già
successa forse ci siamo chiesti ma non è
che c'è un tasto reset anche per la
testa di un insperato diverse volte e
l'ho trovato la buona notizia è che il
pastore set c'è ed è una pratica la
pratica della meditazione
in effetti è semplice perché
probabilmente non serve andare per un
mese sulle montagne dell'himalaya
per quanto bello possa essere per
imparare a respirare
a volte bastano cinque minuti per
rimanere seduti in silenzio ad ascoltare
il suono del silenzio ed è quello che
faremo adesso ci prenderemo cinque
minuti per liberare la nostra mente per
far spazio per tutte le idee del tè dix
che ci attendono
nella giornata di oggi e se c'è qualcuno
tra di voi che non ha mai fatto
meditazione può darsi che in questo
momento provo una sensazione di
irritazione nel coaching lo chiamiamo
perturbazione ed è un ottimo segnale
perché vuol dire che stiamo abbandonando
la zona di comfort per imparare una cosa
nuova
quindi vi chiedo adesso gentilmente di
trovare una posizione comoda
se avete le gambe accavallate appoggiate
entrambi i piedi per terra
se siete seduti sugli sgabelli potete
lasciare i piedi sull'appoggio a piedi
oppure appoggiare almeno buon piede
sulla terra per sentire il contatto
vogliamo aprire il petto per raddrizzare
la schiena
quindi gentilmente portate con me le
spalle innanzitutto in avanti ruotati né
in alto e poi indietro quindi tenete la
schiena dritta senza riggi dirla
i palmi delle mani sono rivolti verso il
basso sulle cosce e chi di voi non vuole
chiudere completamente gli occhi di può
tenere semi aperti fissando un punto
senza focalizzarlo in basso davanti a se
e chi invece come me vuole chiudere gli
occhi
lo faccia adesso
[Musica]
fate apparire lieve suo avviso sulle
vostre labbra
[Musica]
si comincia
ad osservare il tuo respiro
mentre entra ed esce dal card
[Musica]
serve il tuo petto mentre
si alza
e si abbassa
credete un vecchio
per portare la tua attenzione ha il
respiro
[Musica]
e
e ora vai a notare dove si trova la tua
mente in questo momento
forse ti ha portato al passato a cose
che hai vissuto forse che ha portato il
futuro
una cosa che ti aspettano
[Musica]
se è così
non giudicare la tua mente semplicemente
con gentilezza riportano al tuo respiro
[Musica]
e dove si trova la tua mente in questo
momento
è qui nel presente oppure no
se si trova qui
non c'è di carla
gentilezza
riporta la il tuo respiro
[Musica]
e
ed ora ti chiedo fermati di riflettere
sul concetto del un giudizio chiede che
se sei una persona che solitamente
giudica le parole
le idee
[Musica]
le emozioni
le tue
oppure quelle degli altri
[Musica]
si è così
va beh
da vedere se per la giornata di oggi
[Musica]
vuoi portare un atteggiamento di
apertura e di curiosità
[Musica]
e
e quando hai preso la tua decisione
comincia a visualizzare le persone che
sono seduti di fianco a te davanti a te
dietro di te le persone che sono seduti
in alto dove le persone che sono seduti
in basso
le persone che ci stanno seguendo da
casa
[Musica]
e
lì
e fai un sorriso anche a loro
prenditi un attimo per augurare loro
buon giorno
[Musica]
e
e mentre ci avviciniamo alla fine della
nostra pratica ricordati del posto nel
quale ti trovi
mentre muovere leggermente di tali
te le mani e dei piedi
e lentamente con gentilezza apre gli
occhi grazie
io vi ringrazio tantissimo perché questa
mattina avete fatto il primo passo oltre
il convenzionale per alcune persone
forse è stata la prima esperienza di
meditazione e quello che vi chiedo di
fare adesso è il secondo passo oltre al
convenzionale
sì perché tra un po comincerò ad usare
degli aggettivi dedicati al femminile
perché questo è quello che faccio nei
miei podcast di meditazione e perché la
convenzione dice che dobbiamo sempre
tutti sentirci inclusi non importa a
quale genere sessuale apparteniamo
e allora perché non ribaltare questa
convenzione è chiedere a tutti di
sentirsi incluse
non importa a quale genere sessuale
apparteniamo
vi chiedo ora di trovare una posizione
comoda
di appoggiare entrambi i piedi sul
terreno
votiamo insieme alle spalle per trovare
una posizione eretta in avanti in alto e
indietro
apriamo il petto senza irrigidirci
poggiamo i palmi delle mani sulle cosce
e chi vuole tenere i ghetti gli occhi
semichiusi può fare chi invece vuole
chiudere gli occhi
insieme a me lo faccio adesso
[Musica]
cominciano
contrae respiri profondi in spiegheremo
insieme
e quando le spire rai
immagina di avere uno specchio davanti
alla tua bocca che vuoi
appare quindi possiamo fare anche un po
di rumore
inspira ed espira
di nuovo inspira
tedeschi
[Musica]
l'ultima volta di dirlo è spirato
venisse
ed ora per ogni aspirazione immagina di
rilassare una parte in più del tuo corpo
rilascia la fronte
le tempie rilassati occhi
le guance tirasse la lingua rilassa la
mandibola
[Musica]
ed ora chiediti per un attimo come ti
senti
ti senti stanca forse piena d'energia
senti scettica
[Musica]
qualunque sia il modo nel quale ti senti
adesso non c'è giusto o sbagliato è
semplicemente così com'è
[Risate]
[Musica]
e allora ti chiedo di pensare ad una
cosa che ti ha colpito oggi può essere
un'idea
una frase forse una pratica
[Musica]
fermo da ora un'intenzione nella tua
mente prendendo una promessa di te
stessa
[Musica]
si no
penso adesso ad un momento preciso nel
tempo un giorno e unitario nel quale
vuoi iniziare con questa è una pratica
ad integrarla nella tua vita
[Musica]
e quando hai deciso ma nella tua
promessa nei tuoi confronti
ti chiedo ora di portare entrambe le
mani
una sopra l'altra di appoggiarla suo
cuore
e comincia a respirare in questa parte
dell'imputato
[Musica]
santi e battito del suo cuore che batte
senza che poteva fare nulla di
particolare
perché accada
[Musica]
e
e ora ti chiedo di portare nel tuo cuore
il sentimento della gratitudine e con
ogni ispirazione
inspira ancora più gratitudine nel tuo
cuore
[Musica]
e
lì
e se ti può aiutare poi ripetere
silenziosamente dentro di te per tre
volte una dietro l'altra
la parola grazie
e
lì
[Musica]
d
e quando ti senti piena di gratitudine
mente ed estenderla alle persone che
sono sedute di fianco a te
davanti a te
dietro di te e spendita alle persone che
sono seduti in alto e quelle che sono
seduti in basso nelle persone che ci
stanno seguendo a casa
[Musica]
e nota per un attimo come ti senti
ed ora tu a riportare le due mani smith
ha conosciuto e mentre ci avviciniamo
alla fine vento della nostra pratica
ricordati del posto nel quale ti trovi
comincio a sentire i rumori attorno a te
[Musica]
nuovi leggermente le dita delle mani che
i ripieni
e quando 6 previtali
l'africa
[Musica]
grazie